hey guys i'm here with linus and guess
where we are
so that's where you would say like hey
we're here at
my studio you know you're talking to
them well yeah but it's like
a conversation with my studio this is
gonna go
really really well so you guys might
remember linus came to my house and did
a
well i guess you're kind of really kind
making fun of me it was a really kind
tour
this is cute is this just garbage or is
this like a decoration
it's for videos there was also a lot of
wrapping paper more gift wrap what is
this
what is all this gift wrap i don't know
this is like an obsession at the end of
the shoot i was like that's a wrap
oh the jokes are here as well
so today it is a redemption we're gonna
go around and take a little tour of your
office
i'm so excited there are so many cool
things here like i don't really think
i'm gonna be able to make fun of you
but oh i think he'll manage it well one
of the things that is super exciting
is you have a lot of editors
i have me that's a problem
hi jenna what's this little room this is
the library yeah
jenna is actually one of the first
people to ever use this room for what
it's actually intended for
it's supposed to be a quiet place where
you can kind of sit and get some work
done
yeah so we actually turned it into um a
first aid station
because nobody else is ever in here and
this is the one place in the building
where we have like a couch that's big
enough for someone to lie down on in the
event we actually had to use this thing
you do have a lot of things there
yeah so once you have 20 people you have
to have
a safety committee should we test it out
no oh okay
moving along there's an arcade do you
have area 51 on here
uh yeah actually it's sort of broken uh
it's a work in progress yes it's very
much a work in progress i don't even
know how you got that working what is
this running on just
it's just running on a computer this is
my absolute favorite game so my
childhood hobby was to go to arcades
roll in there go find area 51 and then
get the top score and leave
and i did have you played this much ah
no i've never actually played this game
i was more of a house of the dead kid
oh you're playing good let's go i think
yeah we moved back
oh yeah we do okay well only my gun
might be working right now
so you're i've automatically already
lost
i feel like that's the only way that
you'd be able to beat me at it to be
fair
don't shoot him i'm not gonna shoot him
i can tell he's a good guy
i just want to make sure do you want to
shoot barrels or no yes you want barrels
usually you can wait till somebody pops
up because then you can eliminate them
oh crap oh oh crap they're all shooting
at me these guys are back you're killing
your accuracy
is that guy bad he's good blue is good
i'll come back later and get the top
score
okay so we're here where the editors
live
and work do you feed them they don't
live here they're like sometimes
sometimes
so you guys edit everything on premiere
now tell me your process because you
told me earlier like everyone's working
off of server obviously
and how does that all work on the other
side of this wall we have a high speed
storage server so
nvme pci express storage there's one
server that has
over 25 drives in it so about 23
terabytes
of nvme storage and so all of our
current projects go
on there so everyone here has a 10
gigabit so your normal networking is one
gigabit your wireless
networking is like peasant peasant
present
and then 10 gigabit is like full pc
master race like
um so everyone here has a high speed
connection to that server
in order for them to browse reddit
apparently this is an actual subreddit
that is
shockingly active wow this is so
how many editors you guys have so that's
a bit of a complicated question so ed
only edits when we're doing major
projects like scrapyard works but he is
technically an editor but he's also kind
of a production manager yeah and
scheduler a prime is
almost pure editor pella is like 80
editor taran is almost pure editor we
only let him shoot when we're desperate
why do you have 500 keyboards it's only
six keyboards
and you've two stream decks are you
streaming over here when you're not i
want one more stream today
wait what do you use the stream to
explore so you're making fun of him for
the stream decks
but not the box that he eats off of this
is more convenient than having it on the
table that's totally fine i approve i
use
you know boxes for tripods sometimes
yeah so would you eat them on a box
would you eat them with a fox oh if you
go and watch my four and a half hour
long video out of the tutorial
four and a half hours of making a lot of
tech tips video you'll see just how
complex it can get
really you'll understand why i have so
many macro keys what's this
um oh yeah uh that i was trying um some
mind control macros because it's
annoying it takes time to move my hand
over here
this is actually very painful to wear
it's got spikes on it wait are you being
serious right now
yeah this is not a joke no no this
actually works
not very well i don't really know how to
and it's painful
oh yeah it hurts um because the
electrodes have to go through your hair
and you know what else these
have to go on your ears i got some wavy
waves happening on screen but i couldn't
manage to get it to move the cursor
around
as i wanted to i usually when i walk by
here i usually try not to ask too many
questions i go straight for the m
m's yeah but she then spilled all over
the floor
yeah these are floor m ms i definitely
spilled that entire bag on the floor
yesterday i
don't even know what to say i mean i'm
incredibly impressed i i very
strongly believe actually that brain
computer interfaces are the future of
how we interact with computers
one day apple will release an iphone
that doesn't have a touch screen and
they're like no
it's pure brain control no more touch
screen i mean they took away the
headphone jack exactly
so they'll do it that's once it gets
good enough but you know right now it's
do you think we'll get implants so we'll
be able to control it but not at first
people will be against the idea i'm so
down use me for science me too my last
editor is dennis
he's on vacation he's about 60 editor 4d
shooter
bye dennis why does dennis not have mind
control um
i don't even know what to say right now
your editors have mind control
i can't even find one person to edit a
video and you've got like
someone creating mind control technology
where are we now
look at this this is the workshop and
this is the tech linked set
and this is the green screen where we
shoot uh techwiki
wow so we also shot a really fun video
on linus channel it was like a mac vs pc
i was the pc and you were the mac i'm
not sure if anyone
would i think we lost a lot of dignity
a lot of things in this video yeah no
one won so go check that out i'll put a
link in the description and the notation
wherever youtube decides to put them
today
so let's move on let's check this out
you've got a lot of tape
and a lot of paint so this is our clean
rag bin
although this one's wet debatable this
one's wet
put that in there yeah oh boy
a lot of tape a lot of dirty rags uh i
like that you outlined the things
like where to go yeah not very creative
that was actually a my wife initiative
it's great because like you won't you
know exactly where it goes the greatest
part is people will see stuff like this
you have to label the hammer but there's
a rationale that way you know that
this hammer is the workshop hammer
hammer time
measuring tapes i can never find a
measuring tape and you've got 500
linus what what do you see what is
sitting here
i learned no you know what i think
there's probably a good excuse for this
probably one of my most favorite things
that you showed me like you've got all
these
crazy systems for things and it's
incredible we'll come back to this so
we've got to
replace some batteries you want to see
the system for that yes
grab a couple double a's for brandon
you need nine volts oh the nine volts
are here you know it's like i really
want to make fun of you like you're
making fun of me but like i have nothing
to make fun of
so we're in canada if you guys didn't
know and i said this is like chuck e
cheese for me
i was like do you guys even have chuck e
cheese's here which we do they do but
this is so great it's like disney like
this is
look at all these batteries and all
these cameras so we've got
first party red batteries because
they're first party and they're like
quality or something we have these
because they're cheaper and you're only
allowed to carry over a certain milliamp
hour
on a plane so these are within that
limit why do we have so many red
batteries brandon
why not two lights too the amounts yeah
yeah look at this you've got like a
place for your little markers
and like your little cables this is not
nearly as organized as it's supposed to
be
little things so these two stations are
dedicated to footage ingest
uh this one's got three micro sd's two
sds and i believe this is a c fast
and these ones are also 10 gigabit
networking this is
it you guys come over here this is the
sd card
what do you call this i don't know card
board
cardboard so can you explain this
because i don't feel like i'm gonna do
it justice
so it's like basically when you go to
the library and you check out a book so
if i need um an sd card
i would go okay i need an sd card i'm
going to take it off of safe to format
theoretically sd cards are supposed to
be up here but
whatever so then i put that under my
name and then i take the sd card
yes now this sd card is in my custody
and everyone knows because the label on
the card matches the label on the holder
so then
this either needs to be in a camera or
in a reader
or go back in here for safe keeping yeah
uh mine are sitting all over my desk
and my dog once ate one but sanders
replaced it for me when i tweeted about
my dog eating it yeah
wow thanks guys it was really i
appreciate it he did spit it back up so
he didn't swallow it i mean we're not
perfect there's this hard drive sitting
here that says return to brandon here
you go brandon
i actually don't know what's in here
apparently a bunch of random random crap
lights apparently we have a label maker
i love label makers and clearly
we clearly didn't use it oh you didn't
use
a label maker for the label maker i
think i could fit in this roman case
like this is really massive
warm up the donuts you warm up donuts
10 seconds man yes no it's like this
oh what's this that's a panini grill
do you guys use it often yes really it's
brandon's from home
from home and that's literally been here
for five years so what we're back where
we started
well wait a minute what's all in here oh
my gosh
these windows are new we just got
windows in our office
wow oh my god i'm so middle level is
that like a
mac job yeah i think so i've seen
behind this door before and it is
it's very exciting would you like me to
open up yes sure
oh my god
go ahead you do the honors
i could use a label maker yeah i could
this is so close this is like
beyond precise there is like a
fingernail
of space between opening this door i
would say i never noticed but i
definitely did that was uh
there was a remounting effort that was
made
as you can see i'm also at the very edge
of where i managed to adjust it to
oh my gosh nice and cool in here good
job yeah we uh we
underestimated how much air conditioning
we needed we added our petabyte of
storage in the bottom here
and then it started overheating in here
so we had to add a second
air conditioner where are we
now this is where the writers keep all
the
junk that they need for current projects
that overflows from the upstairs oh
these are coolers for quadros
that are have the cards stripped out and
then they're water cooled
this is cable land so if you need a sata
cable with a flat connector then you dig
under the right angle connectors that
doofuses put on top of them i don't know
if you needed one of these
i mean we went to best buy i remember
what we needed it's like a vga cable or
something
yeah we need the most compact one oh
that's real compact yeah this looks
pretty good this is an 18
cable these things are worth like one
dollar
you want another vga uh you know i think
i actually we never even ended up using
it and i've never used
it since i've just moved it around what
do you think the oldest piece of tech is
that you have here
oh we'd probably have to go into like
general inventory land still here's fans
oh it's some fans
okay why do you need this many fans
minus tech tips has the best fans
no offense to your fans your fans are
great too but our fans are black and
orange
why do you have some special linus tech
tips and a lot of people ask what
happens to the builds when we're done
because we're constantly building pcs we
tear them down and put them on the shelf
that makes sense there's bins of like
actual bins
yeah these are just more like utility
fans or fans that people ruined because
they're idiots
does anybody need like a mouse is this a
yoga mat
no that is the world's biggest mouse pad
what this is kind of a two-person job
this is actually a very nice yoga mat
maybe you guys can start doing
yoga yoga videos tech tips
nobody wants that they probably do they
probably don't you want lioness doing
yoga the ones that do want that i don't
want to watch it
oh look you brought a little bit of
outside inside it was
actually found like in the garbage and
it's just kind of a sentimental thing
this is from back when i used to work at
the store
this is where you'll probably find older
stuff so this is sort of
inventory land so this is all like
networking and like thunderbolt
um this is add-in cards that are not
graphics cards so like
network cards usb cards that kind of is
like this motherboard's gotta be 10
years old probably
i don't know like i honestly i'm in here
all the time i feel like this is so
boring
this is so exciting okay i don't know i
mean i'm not sure if my audience is
gonna think it's super exciting but like
i'm super excited about it so this is
uh this is part of props this is costume
land okay
uh there's a whole other prop section i
didn't even show you yet behind there
i found there's an old piece of tech the
old tech so we specifically bought that
phone
for a piece that we did on sort of like
then versus now
technology and like you know our parents
and stuff we just kind of bought it as a
prop we've actually used it a handful of
times
a fan says oh okay i wasn't just i
wasn't gonna ask questions
i was asking questions maybe just put it
oh it's on both sides so
she makes me uncomfortable
it's kind of supposed to be a bedroom
slash like
gaming area is that a real door but it
doesn't really go
anywhere this is our pig do you know the
pigs are my favorite animal
that's so cool it's just a big thing
yeah i wanted to get a pig
where i lived in los angeles i wasn't
zoned to own a pig so this gives us
a realistic foliage effect on the on the
curtains
on the inside of the set and this is
where all of our networking comes
through
this condo is not just for show
it's actually wired for power so all the
outlets actually work in it oh cool and
then all of the ethernet jacks actually
work this is a christmas tree
yeah i love it can you believe someone
was getting rid of that
i can't oh it's definitely seen better
days
i feel like there's a lot of places that
you can get stuck
or tangled or fall see i never feel like
that until i bring like an outsider in
because for me like i only really go
watch it okay
this is the bike that tyrion brings to
work to say that wasn't there earlier
you have so much stuff like it's crazy
that's actually mine from when i was a
kid his lightsaber
flows so more stuff more overflow for
current projects
this is the other side of what we just
saw the last time i was here this was
not here look at the kitchen yes now
look away
what's missing from what the kitchen a
stove
actually that too oh
it also doesn't have a fridge that's
what the space was for but then
we would lose this kind of nook thing
this is really funny though
so this not real yeah but that doesn't
prevent people from dumping things down
it so we have to keep buckets
because you would think if no one knows
i would do the same thing
you'd walk in you'd go oh a sink but
there's an iphone here
this whole uh countertop and all the
drawers are fake
is that just one of the standing desks
yeah it's an up desk so it was just
modded into it so that way
whether we're sitting or standing or
whatever you can adjust
i'm ripping out my entire center console
in my kitchen now
because this is amazing we've got a
living room over here
this is amazing this looks so great i
love it yeah my wife did
all mo uh no i shouldn't say all but she
did most of the
like design mess of the walls and like
the floors and colors and
a lot of the furniture and the greatest
vacuum of all time
have you guys seen one of these
only every single tech youtuber did an
unboxing review of it
so we're actually using it we use it to
clean our set i use it all the time um
we did we talked about this
your different sets here oh my gosh
there's so many things over there oh
there's our new drill press
we didn't even go wait did we go over
there no you've got a little workshop
yeah so this is kind of temporary right
now but this will be turned into a more
complete workshop this for our project
we're making our own computer heat sink
this is our laser cutter
so you can use this to cut acrylic or
like balsa wood or whatever else
you need to wear safety glasses if it's
open or whatever but no no it's fine
that's fine
this is from our mining experiment a
little while ago i don't think it's
actually running
right now what were you mining uh
ethereum yeah i should have sold a long
time ago
this is going to be an interesting
project so jake is taking the old 16k
gaming setup gonna be
three high three wide curved
10k oh that's right because it's 34.40
so 10ish k
there's nothing really over here that's
that interesting swag for
our upcoming convention oh so ltx18
these are the lanyards that people are
going to be able to get apparently got
motherboards
mice all kinds of good stuff so the swag
is real
can i can i go this is like a sprawling
just
never ending place we very rarely show a
lot of it on camera actually like i'm
sorry will tell me if
you made it no that's fine like people
mostly just see the sets but like it
doesn't matter
blueberry here's more christmas
ornaments
with this reflective insulation we could
reflectively
insulate something just
these are the lids for all of our
rubbermaid bins because
they all come with lids right yes but
nobody uses the lids
rarely but you don't want to throw them
away in case you'll ever need one huge
note on this
feel free to show it to the camera this
monitor is damaged so you probably
shouldn't use it the exact details of
what's wrong with it are recorded in
inventory management system as a huge
waste of time and effort to write it all
again here is this a joke i'm sure
whoever made that note wrote it in
earnest here's our archery tag
stuff no no there's no there's okay i
bet i could fit in that too
it's like my favorite thing to do is
like find a suitcase or something and
see if i can fit in it
everybody's got to have a hobby i mean
i've got a few
so this pops out in case we ever had to
use a forklift to lift a pallet up here
i feel like you guys have actually
thought of every scenario for everything
oh no
do you guys have earthquakes here uh we
haven't in a long time but we are
overdue for a big one
you guys dare i say you've got a lot of
wood
so there's a lot of it here that's very
risque for you
it's everywhere what's in here
what um this is a linus tech tips
beanbag chair would you like one
no i will happily ship it to you i'm
okay okay i'm okay with things it's
worth a shot
it's okay i'm trying to get rid of my
own beer bags i have in my house so
would you like another one
no no good now where do we go one is we
haven't even went to your office yet no
or upstairs
no did you write laugh out loud
on tape except to be that we had um
a different alarm system so this tape
was here so that you could put it on
here
so that people would know that it's
armed this is my big tub of mineral oil
for what for cooling computers oh
submerging the minute
i mean oh no that's a really
sharp light are you okay no i'm fine
what's this
that's a bug zapper yeah these things
yeah
i hope this isn't just tedious for you
oh i'm having the best freaking time
do i need a beanbag maybe you need
another beanbag no i don't think i need
another beanbag i have many beanbags
look there's so many oh that's probably
not good for the audio
i'll sit gently
these are for meetings oh look it's the
startings of a desk
yeah yeah it's like a baby desk this is
our
graphic designer slash merch managers
with a cpu on it for some reason
swatches he's a mac these used to give
me nightmares because i actually used to
be a graphic designer
just kidding these are like 300 or
something so expensive yeah because
they're very specific colors too
that's ridiculous how do they get away
with that how do they still get away
with this is what i'd like to know
oh there he is he's not past his
probation so he's not allowed to be on
camera
yet
she found a kindred spirit this is the
lunch table
that people requested and never used
why is it so small well that's probably
why they never use
it so apparently we use luke's office
just for storage because he's never in
it hmm that's weird
that is a virtual boy oh my god we were
gonna do a video
uh but we couldn't figure out how to
screen cap it no
way this is actually amazing it works
only ever seen this at like the nintendo
store and it's like behind a glass
he's sort of a retro uh retro collector
that's amazing
i got this one oh these are great these
are for organizing screws
oh because they're magnetic yeah so if
you great
have like some crap that you don't want
to lose then it can't fall out
i thought they were dog bowls this one's
important
to touch any more things so where are we
now this is where
my writing team and um people that write
things for you
yeah ivan james anthony jake
and alex and john is still on the
writing team but he has relocated back
to north carolina
so his old office is actually empty
right now
i love north carolina this is the rave
pc by the way
this is so great this is everything
i guess i can just say this is
everything because that's what the kids
say there's an actual laser show built
into it so if we have uh like a fog
machine
like we can spray fog through the front
and you'll be able to see the laser
lights kind of dancing around inside of
course there is
yeah it makes me feel so much better
about all of my like nerdy interests
when i was like growing up
just knowing that there's other people
that like you've definitely exceeded
i can i can go one higher than that if
you want no i'm sure i've seen a lot of
things today here's our next
uh crazy ridiculous alex project
so this is a remote control
uh water plane we are planning to make
it into a working pc
that's the plan to fly yeah yeah okay
take land and plug in and
browse the internet who flies it uh i'll
try
okay i haven't flown one in a long time
oh my gosh
this is my wife's office so she does all
of our accounting
and being pink and sparkly it's so
pretty
so the best part about this is she did
not decorate it
you guys did yes it was me and one of
our ex-employees nick van burkel
oh i have the same one i feel like
probably every youtuber does
yeah i mean it's handy it's so great
people don't know
but i'm a bit of a badminton nerd this
is a peter godda
jersey he was a famous danish player so
you've got the motherboard wall which
seems to be the the famous staple of
i love this thing it's so cool i think
no it's great look and you can even hang
stuff on it yeah that's pretty awesome
so i've got my
oh look at those it's great these are
mine i love them
i like your little this is nice this usb
thing
oh yeah that's super handy you want to
have to charge a bunch of junk
it's like i have one but it's not this
nice i just use it to charge all my
mophies but yet i can never find a movie
when i need it in this desk oh what's
that
that's not some wrapping oh that's
princess wrapping paper that's weird
why do you have all this wrapping paper
here linus
like what could you possibly need
wrapping paper
they planted this they planted this
i know they planted this this is even
the kind of wrapping paper i would use
to be honest there's another one okay
where is it
where where is is there any more where
is it all i don't know i actually did it
shut up i did it shut up this is yours
this is not my i didn't do this how long
is there more stuff that i didn't see i
don't think so because this happened so
long ago because
this tour is insane that i forgot about
the wrapping paper
so i wasn't even looking for it we could
lightsaber you could probably
you stole a sticker no i didn't what are
you talking about i still had a while
ago how much stuff have you been lifting
as we've been going through here that
would have
i might we need to reshoot i should have
been stealing things this whole time
but i wasn't oh this is my favorite
piece of fan art ever
like it's a it's like a great ugly
picture that's a fantastic
representation of me
here's uh my gift for you which actually
nick bought this
he went oh dorchester so you had a
co-conspirator
spoiler well thank you again uh if you
guys want to see the video that we did
together i'll put a link in the
description make sure you guys go check
that out and go check out lion's channel
and subscribe if you like
very very techy things but i'd like that
you're kind of doing a little i mean
it's techie but it's a little more
relatable too yeah we're trying to find
a ballet
it's hard if you don't like it it's okay
it's very specific but it's very very
good
is that is that a way to say it i'm not
sure anyway i've been a huge fan for so
long so this is so great to just
see everything i love it cool well
that's the end of the video oh you
missed my uh is there anything else
you missed my do not disturb sign made
of old floppy disks
that's so incredible
you guys have everything labeled there's
one thing that i saw you didn't have
labeled
i'm gonna have to make you a label for
it cool
well that's it that's right i only stole
one thing
so we stopped the video we ended it but
we're back because
there's another one there's one more
nick did such good love hiding it that
is frozen
it is a great movie i only recently saw
it
and it was i what
i'm too busy editing videos and i'm time
to watch movies and i really don't have
children and my dog
likes animal planet so that's what we
watch
i mean i know the song so you knew the
song but you hadn't even seen the movie
i saw it eventually you're a poser
i haven't seen the movie literally but
you don't sing the song
let it go
technically you bought this for yourself
so oh i paid for it too venmo
do you guys have venmo in canada uh
i actually have no idea okay no if
they're mine then they're mine
there you go presents with it okay
that's it
end of video
[Music]